[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un bonsoir à tous lundi 9 avril début
d'une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans cette
édition
tout de suite les titres de se situer du
journal y aura-t-il bientôt une nouvelle
ville dans saint quentin en yvelines
maurepas et coignières vont annoncer ce
lundi midi leur intention de fusionner
un rassemblement dans une commune
nouvelle pour faire face notamment aux
baisses des dotations de l'état les
explications à suivre les européennes se
dérouleront l'an prochain et certaines
formations politiques sont déjà dans les
starting blocks la république en marche
a lancé ce week end sa grande marche
pour le scrutin dans les yvelines le
lancement s'est tenue en présence dé de
la ministre des affaires européennes
nathalie loiseau et puis c'est un rendez
vous annuel attrape le forum emploi se
tient ce mercredi au gymnase broustal
l'événement est dédié aux stages et jobs
d'été mais aussi à l'apprentissage plus
de 40 entreprises seront présentes nous
en parlons avec larbi toit hier
conseiller municipal à trappes et autres
invités de ce journal les deux
fondateurs du mouvement européen saint
quentin en yvelines ils organisent ce
mercredi une conférence débat à maurepas
c'est à suivre dans ce journal
l'actualité du jour d'abord marquée par
le 2e acte de la grève perlée a la sncf
les cheminots ont entamé à nouveau un
deuxième jour de grève ce lundi pour
protester contre le projet de réforme
ferroviaire
après une nouvelle journée de galère
aujourd'hui le mouvement doit prendre
fin demain mardi à 8 heures le retour à
la normale devrait s'effectuer dans la
journée en moyenne ce sera à 4 trains
sur 5 sur l'ensemble du réseau en
ile-de-france trafic compliqué sur la
ligne c trois trains sur cinq
le trafic sera normal en revanche sur
les lignes n et u et des deux prochains
jours de grève sont programmés ce
vendredi et samedi et la grève n'impacte
pas que les usagers mais aussi les
commerces aux abords de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines
certains restaurateurs ont enregistré
une diminution de la fréquentation dans
leur établissement à 25 à 30 % de
clients en moins
en ces jours de grève écoutez ces deux
professionnels installés dans la
diagonale à montigny le bretonneux
interrogé par camille lambert et marion
ptac beaucoup moins de monde je pense
que les gens soient ils viennent pas
parce que comme il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'entreprises et de sièges sur
sur 50 un don qui irait chez deux
peut-être du télétravail ou ou autre
mais en tout cas nous on les a pas chez
vous avez moins de clients qui se
présentent le matin du fait que moins de
tra ou des gens le midi qui ne viennent
pas parce que ils ont passé du temps le
matin
heureusement il ya le calendrier des
grèves qui est en ligne donc va par
rapport à ces jours là on regarde
l'historique de l'année - et
la boule de cristal en six ans bah allez
on va limiter les gars - 20 à - 25
côté local l'actualité de ce lundi 9
avril cette annonce faite ce midi par
les maires de maurepas et coignières les
deux villes veulent fusionner une
commune nouvelle qui pourrait déjà
revoir le jour au 1er janvier 2019 ce
rassemblement permettrait notamment de
mutualiser les moyens face à des
dotations de l'état en baisse les
détails avec ce sujet d'aurélie rond et
marion ptac ans sur l'ensemble une
volonté commune pour un nouvel ensemble
territorial coignières et maurepas
partagent déjà un même code postal de
nombreux projets intercommunaux archives
déchetterie police municipale un centre
aquatique et bientôt une nouvelle
identité
il faut qu'on aille justement dans cette
formidable aventure qui est historique
pour nos habitants et audacieuse en
termes de qualité services publics et de
services publics on va proposer à nos
habitants c'est à dire de toujours faire
mieux avec nos moyens
une décision partie motivée par la
baisse des dotations de l'état ne
souhaitant pas augmenter les impôts les
maires de coignières et maurepas ont
décidé de s'unir
un mariage qui devrait intervenir le 1er
janvier 2019
depuis 2010 la loi permet en effet aux
communes de regrouper leurs
administrations respectives
actuellement en france il existe cinq
cent cinquante sept communes nouvelles
un nouveau mode de fonctionnement qui
sera exposée à la population dans les
prochaines semaines il y aura besoin
d'information d'écouté de compréhension
aussi de la population de nos
administrés et donc c'est une phase
d'ici à la fin de l'année et je dirais
même à l'automne d'ici à l'automne c'est
une phase très très importante
on ne fait pas pour nous on le fait pour
les habitants pour garantir une qualité
de service public qui est tant attendu
par nos populations
un projet d'avenir qui donnera lieu à de
nombreux changements un seul maire mais
aussi un nouveau nom pour cette commune
nouvelle nous aurons besoin d'une
votation besoin de l'avis de la
population et il faudra conserver
également l'esprit mort passe bien mais
aussi l'esprit coignières dans le dos
dans le dans le nom de cette nouvelle
commune et ce sera déterminée d'ici
d'ici quelques mois henri dès cette
semaine les habitants de maurepas et
coignières recevront une lettre
explicative sur cette ambition commune
et pour parler de ce projet de fusion le
maire de maurepas grégory d'ariste y est
celui de coignières jean-pierre sevestre
seront nos invités ce mercredi soir dans
le 7-8 journal je vous le disais dans
les titres et les élections européennes
sont au programme en 2019 ce week-end la
république en marche a lancé
officiellement sa campagne pour le
scrutin est la grande marche pour
l'europe
à cette occasion dans les yvelines la
ministre des affaires européennes
nathalie l'oiseau s'est rendu à la
maison jean monnet de bazoches un lieu
symbolique où ont été rédigées les
premiers actes prémices de la création
de l'union européenne reportage de
nicolas landry
la grande marche pour l'europe
yvelinoise lancée avec une visite de la
maison jean monnet la ministre chargé
des affaires européennes a pu découvrir
la résidence d'un père fondateur de
l'union européenne son salon sa chambre
ou encore des documents officiels
prémices de la création communautaire
mme voyer la méthode monnet rien est
impossible rien on ne s'interdit aucune
idée quand on est face à un péril
en un an on est passé d'un texte un
traité ce qui est très frappant ses
devoirs quand on parle avec les
responsables de la maison jean monnet
que jean monnet travailler en
rencontrant des gens de toutes
catégories socioprofessionnelles de
toutes origines
en les écoutant pour construire ces
projets c'est exactement la même
démarche que la grande marche pour
l'europe
plusieurs militants de la république en
marche ont échangé avec la ministre des
discussions sur les compétences
européennes les défis climatiques et
migratoires ou encore la révolution
numérique
des questions qui devraient revenir
durant la grande marche le point de
départ pour élaborer le projet européen
des élections en 2019 par exemple n'ont
pas là kaminis de lycées professionnels
qui ont été rendues possibles grâce au
soutien de l'union européenne ue s'est
montré qu'elle est dans notre quotidien
est juste sur des aspects de
réglementation parce que c'est souvent
comme ça qu'elle est un peu caricaturé
mais elle est là aussi pour nous
protéger et pour nous faire grandir ce
qu'on souhaite vraiment tirer c'est
d'avoir des réponses concrètes aux
problématiques quotidiennes qui se
posent aux yvelinois yaws yvelinoise
parce que nous pensons que sur des
thématiques comme l'économie comme
l'environnement comme la sécurité
l'europe détient une part de solutions
les marcheurs vont faire du porte à
porte dans plus de 90 communes des
yvelines
une campagne prévue sur cinq semaines
l'europe justement c'est leur conviction
bonsoir viviane boussier vous est la
cofondatrice du mouvement européen de
saint quentin en yvelines avec votre
avec notre autre invité christian franck
bonsoir mon choix le mouvement européen
c'est une association qui agit en faveur
de la construction européenne votre
antenne locale organise ce mercredi 11
avril à 20h30 en mairie ne mord pas une
conférence débat son nom union
européenne et mythes et mensonges on va
la présenter au cours de cet entretien
déjà un petit tour de table on va
commencer avec vous madame bouyssié dans
un contexte où on parle de pro-européens
d'anti-européen pourquoi vous vous avez
fait le choix de l'europe pourquoi vous
êtes une européenne convaincue
eh bien pourquoi je suis tout simplement
si vous ne peut strictement rien faire
sans l'europe
donc en fait on ne peut pas comprendre
même à la limite pourquoi on ne peut pas
être européens tous les tous les grandes
problématiques actuelles que ce soit je
suis pas moi le terrorisme la crise la
population que ce soit les problèmes
environnementaux tous les problèmes que
vous prenez rien n'est possible sans une
sans une action européenne donc j'ai
rien que ça c'est déjà une raison
christian franck pourquoi es tu revois
un européen convaincu
je suis un européen convaincu parce que
comme viviane je pense que l'europe est
incontournable on a devant nous des
blocs politiques économiques qui nous
enserre que ce soit l'asie les états
unis et si nous ne réagissons pas on va
se faire avoir
on le voit bien avec la technologie
google est américain pourquoi ne pas
avoir aussi d'être notre propre
technologie où que ce soit pour le civil
ou pour l'armée on a l'impression tout
de même que la question européenne
passionne peu les français quand on
prend les dernières élections
européennes en 2014
42 43 % ça c'était le taux de
participation un taux assez faible
puisque vous avez si cette impression
que ça cette question européenne
passionne peu encore les français peu je
ne sais pas pas assez c'est sûr j'ai un
petit peu l'impression qu'étant donnée
justement les problèmes auxquels
christian faisait allusion et moi avant
aussi je pense qu'il ya peut-être un
besoin d'europe qui se fait sentir un
petit peu plus maintenant que ce soit la
mondialisation et tous les problèmes qui
touchent et il est possible que ça ça
joue quand même peut-être sur la
mobilisation
justement christian tran que le
mouvement européen qui est leur rôle
joue-t-il peut-être dans la dent de la
pédagogie à avoir auprès des français
auprès des européens à quel est son rôle
au mouvement européen justement je pense
que le maître mot c'est pédagogie
d'ailleurs le mouvement européen vient
d'être agréé comme association à but
pédagogique
c'est un mouvement international est un
mouvement international international en
europe avec des représentations dans les
pays les caleçons / section nous notre
appartenant à la section des yvelines
d'accord et donc il est son propre rôle
oui c'est la pédagogie c'est
l'information c'est le débat c'est les
échanges en faveur de la meilleure
connaissance de l'europe et pourquoi
lancer une antenne à saint quentin en
yvelines
justement c'est tout simplement parce
que saint quentin c'est quand même deux
cents presque 230 mille habitants
c'est une agglomération qui vit et donc
on a vraiment senti le besoin nécessité
la raison pour créer une antenne sur ces
douze villes de l'agglomération
actuellement c'est une dizaine de
membres qui fait partie de
de cette antenne locale c'est ça c'est
une vingtaine de membres de
l'encadrement dont 17 ans 10 actifs qui
font du prosélytisme en ce moment alors
on l'a dit le moment européen antenne de
saint quentin en yvelines organise ce
mercredi 11 avril à 20h30 une conférence
débat à maurepas union européenne mythe
et mensonges
il ya beaucoup d'idées reçues sur
l'union européenne qu'il faut
déconstruire ces c'est aussi pour ça
vous proposer ces examens exactement le
pour le coup je crois que l'effectif
elles sont elles sont bien là et etc
lives qui justement présente ce débat
étant franco anglais a vécu le bric site
a eu à entendu vu tout les oublis pour
reprendre le titre de de ce débat tous
les mythes et les mensonges qui tournait
sur le bric citer les les faux arguments
qui étaient là donc il est bien placé
pour en parler
lesquels idées à déconstruire selon vous
christian franck peut être un exemple on
a parlé du bric site il ya d'autres
thèmes qui seront peut-être abordé
mackenzie déconstruire vous savez quand
ça va pas c'est toujours la faute des
autres
et en l'occurrence c'est la faute de
l'europe donc l'idée à déconstruire
c'est que c'est que c'est pas forcément
de la faute de l'europe d'abord qui sait
quand on dit c'est la faute de l'europe
derrière suit c'est la faute de
bruxelles
enfin il faut quand même bien savoir
qu'on a des représentants politiques qui
sont là bas que ce soit les chefs d'état
où que ce soit les députés ce sont eux
qu'on envoie là-bas ce sont eux qui font
bruxelles quand de bruxelles ne va pas
ce sont deux qui n'ont pas fait leur
boulot et le
et donc notre vocation justement cette
sensibiliser la population a envoyé à
bruxelles des gens des gens politique
des politiques compétents gros européen
de façon à reconstruire quelque chose de
cohérent
les deux puissants alors il nous reste
30 secondes précise juste que pour ce
rendez-vous l'entrée est libre
ce mercredi il y aura d'autres choses
mises en place par le mouvement européen
de 50 ans ni blessé c'est notre premier
débat mais on pense bien organiser des
choix des des apéritifs soit des débats
soient des soirées pour les
consultations citoyennes
voilà merci à vous de viviane broussy à
christian franck d'avoir été avec nous
au confluent batteur du mouvement
européen saint-quentin-en-yvelines je
rappelle que cette conférence débat est
programmé ce mercredi
rendez vous à 20h30 en mairie de
maurepas elle a dû saint-quentinoise
justement qui dispose d'un nouvel espace
pour la petite enfance l'escale réunis
en un seul lieu plusieurs établissements
du secteur
cette structure située à deux pas de la
halle du marché a ouvert ses portes en
janvier reportage de mélanie poker des
pièces plus lumineuse divers services
proposés à l'escale aujourd'hui trois
services de la petite enfance
travaillent en collaboration
chaque espace est interconnecté comme on
dit ce qui fait qu si on a le personnel
municipal qui peut travailler dans le
parcours de l'enfant
et puis c'est aussi au centre ville donc
beaucoup plus accessible nous avons
regroupé l'ensemble de ces structures
la microcrèche leur relation maternelle
qui était dans le quartier des friches
et l'espace enfants par an
dans des lieux un lieu beaucoup plus
grand plus de 300 m² dédiés aux enfants
de moins de trois ans avec 20 berceaux
pour la ltte jeu et dix enfants dans la
micro crèche une nouvelle structure
ouverte deux mois plus tôt est déjà
victime de son succès sur la micro
crèche en reste à 10 enfants puisque de
toute façon c'est la norme
on ne peut pas commenter des dix enfants
mais sur l'espace enfants parents et
même au niveau du relais assistants
maternels la fréquentation est beaucoup
plus importante depuis qu'on est au
centre-ville avant l espace enfants
parents n'accueillait 5 6 enfants par
accueille là on arrive à 14,15 par
l'accueil situé dans l'ancien espace
solidarité l'escale a nécessité un
budget de 2 128 mille euros plus de
soixante mille euros ont été
subventionnés par la caisse
d'allocations familiales direction à
présent sentir l'école la quatrième
édition des universités du goût se
tenait ce samedi aux fermes de gally
thématique cette année la mémoire et le
goût autour de plusieurs conférences et
témoignages et des astuces et des
conseils aussi autour de la nutrition
glanées par nicolas dans l'os du bébé
gastronomes à la nutrition plaisir et
santé dès l'enfance
les thématiques d'ouverture de la 4ème
édition des universités du goût
organisée aux fermes de gally les
nourrissons au coeur des échanges avec
le public et des questions sur les
comportements alimentaires à adopter
c'est un rendez vous annuel de réflexion
pour moi réflexion sur ce que je mange
sur ce que je fais manger à mes amis à
mes enfants
ça m'apporte énormément j'ai appris que
l'allaitement était quand même très
favorables sur le goût et la mémoire du
goût et l'initiation du goût chez les
enfants des spécialistes en médecine en
neurosciences ou des agriculteurs
différentes disciplines pour parler de
la mémoire du goût des souvenirs qui se
construisent dès l'enfance avec des
astuces pour faire aimer certains
aliments comme les légumes les enfants
sont très gourmands de bonnes soupes et
de bons légumes à bons légumes se
présentent pas dans une assiette comme
ça fige et sans sauce il faut jouer avec
le légume et l'enfant est donc là les
enfants ensuite auront l'habitude ci le
prenne dès leur première aliments comme
on l'a expliqué que ce soit dans la
terra tueur ce soit dans les arts ou ce
soit dans la cuisine il est très
important à un moment donné qui a un
rapport qu'on se souvienne d'eau d'où on
vient et on se souvient d'où on vient
quand au moment donné on se souvient de
sa première mediène de sa première bière
on a parlé ou pop du premier biscuit
qu'on aime qu'on a pu qu'on a pu avaler
des souvenirs permettant de se
construire une culture nutritionnelle
une culture en constante évolution à
mettre en harmonie entre santé et
plaisir alimentaire une compte à béton
de 61 mètres d'envergure la plus grande
de france vous l'avez peut être vu en
fin de semaine dernière sur le pont
schuller entre la verrière et mord pas
une opération de coulage de béton a été
effectuée le but recouvrir les
poutrelles métalliques à base de la
structure sur une épaisseur de 25 m
rappelez-vous les travaux de doublement
de voix de l'édifice enjambant la
nationale 10 sont ont débuté en février
2010 est le chantier est chiffré à 9,4
millions d'euros c'est ce mercredi au
gymnase broustal attrape le forum de
l'emploi et de l'apprentissage va réunir
une quarantaine d'entreprises
elles proposeront des offres d'emploi en
cdi cdd jobs d'été ce stage mais aussi à
des contrats d'apprentissage et de
professionnalisation pour en parler
larbi toit hier bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller municipal de la ville de
trappes délégué aux relations et la mise
en
des partenariats entre les domaines
économique et éducatif déjà cette
question sur l'emploi et l'insertion des
jeunes quelle importance at-elle cette
thématique pour la ville de trappes
mais les capitales en fait puisque nous
lors de ce mandat on a mis un accent
très fort sur la jeunesse sur l'emploi
est naturellement l'insertion
professionnelle
c'est une problématique récurrente
malheureusement pour nos concitoyens et
donc dé l'année dernière on a voulu
créer ce forum est en tout cas hors
revitaliser le forum jobs d'été
les dernières en mettant l'accent dans
un premier temps sur le forum de
l'apprentissage d'accord et cette année
grâce aux entreprises qui sont de plus
en plus présente et de plus en plus
partenaire de la ville aller sur le
terrain de l'emploi est justement de
pouvoir proposer des cdi c'est ça depuis
un an les événements évoluent en plus
des traditionnels stages et jobs d'été
il est également possible de trouver au
forum sur l'alternance et son
apprentissage
pourquoi faire évoluer l'offre est ce
que les jeunes de trappes avait des
difficultés à trouver un emploi en
apprentissage dans une formation en
apprentissage ou en alternance
ben oui aujourd'hui pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens en france comme attrape le
premier emploi peut se trouver via un
réseau via des contacts que l'on peut
avoir un entreprises via le réseau des
parents ou des voisins
je vais pas vous cacher 4 ap c'est un
peu plus difficile et donc on avait à
coeur de vraiment poussé ces jeunes à la
rencontre des entreprises est plutôt que
de les forcer à eux aller à l'extérieur
du territoire vous voulez aussi leur
montrer que les entreprises étaient
favorables à venir les rencontrer au
sein de leur territoire au sein de leur
ville et ceci est un message fort et
pour cela je remercie les entreprises
qui font le déplacement du coup quels
sont les objectifs d'un tel événement on
imagine des objectifs auprès des jeunes
mais aussi auprès des entreprises
présentes pour les entreprises présentes
c'est de justement s'intéresser à notre
population à nos jeunes n'est pas
forcément à toutes les personnes qui
sont à la recherche d'un emploi et de
resserrer les liens avec la ville parce
qu'on a des talents parce que on a des
personnes qui sont capables
d'entreprendre intra prendre qui sont
euh qu'informer et qui sont fiers de
venir chercher du travail sur la ville
quand bien même agents ont été formés
sur d'autres villes en région parisienne
ou en france plus de 40 entreprises
seront présentes sur ce forum de
l'emploi de l'apprentissage ça a été
facile de les convaincre de participer à
cet événement oui alors cette année
c'est la deuxième opération donc c'est
plus facile à l'espace de venir mais dès
l'année dernière en fait on avait connu
un franc succès puisqu'on était l'année
dernière à 40 entreprises est limité par
la taille du gymnase guimier donc cette
année on va être sur broustal un gymnase
un peu plus grands qui nous permet
d'avoir signer les 45 entreprises plus
les stands de nos partenaires la mission
locale pôle emploi la cité des métiers
saas cet événement se fait pas sans des
partenariats avec ces c'est un événement
avec les partenaires locaux avec les
entreprises comme josé qui travaillent
avec nous dans le cadre de la création
d'une alliance territoriales piloté par
auchan est en vie et donc voilà c'est un
tissu économique qui se crée qui est que
l'on essaye de manier au mieux avec
notre besoin mais surtout le besoin des
personnes en recherche d'emploi
le profil des entreprises présentes quel
est il alors on a plusieurs secteurs où
on va avoir
lassé des services des banques
on a des entreprises liées au monde du
transport
on a des gros groupes des petits groupes
d des entreprises du de chrysalide aussi
je pensais à belle cote avec notamment
donc on a des renault airbus et en même
temps on a des petites structures du
service à la personne et on a aussi des
partenaires qui vont nous aider à
préparer nos jeunes donc à pouvoir
réimprimer des cv recorrigé quelques
phrases puisqu'on a quand même des
phrases d'across on les forme c'est
aussi pour un terrain d'apprentissage
aussi pour aller se présenter et
accrocher un peu les entreprises 200
offres au total qui seront présentés
deux cents oeuvres seront présentées sur
voilà comme vous le disiez de
l'apprentissage du cdi et on espère
qu'elles seront
tout pourvu à la fin pour ce don qui
viendront mercredi quels conseils vous
pourriez leur donner il faut venir
j'imagine avec plusieurs cv avec
peut-être une tenue appropriée je ne
sais pas préparé son discours aussi il
ya des choses voilà tout à fait vous
c'est surtout venir avec quelques cv
mais c'est surtout préparer et
documenter le besoin des entreprises qui
vont être présentes il s'agit pas de
venir et faire le tour de toutes les
entreprises
il faut s'aimer et ciblées donc ça c'est
un message que l'on a eu tout au long de
l'année notamment avec lé partenariat
avec le tissu éducatif pour ceux qui
sont encore dans le domaine éducatif
pour ceux qui sont à la recherche d'un
emploi c'est des choses que pôle emploi
la mission locale sensibilise mais en
effet il faut venir préparer tenue
adéquate
mais l'année dernière on n'a pas eu
beaucoup de problèmes là tu donc je
pense que nos concitoyens seront au
rendez vous nous resterons de seconde
qu'elle attende vous avez sur sur cet
événement du coup le deuxième forum du
genre de l'emploi de l'apprentissage ah
bah j'espère que les entreprises nous
ferons un retour aussi favorable que
l'année dernière puisqu'elle avait été
agréablement surprise de la première
édition donc on espère que cette
deuxième édition sera tout aussi réussie
et on espère dépasser les 1000
participants l'année dernière nous
étions à 1 700 visiteurs
merci à l'arbitré d'avoir été avec nous
merci et à ce forum de l'emploi et de
l'apprentissage c'est ce mercredi 11
avril au gymnase broustal rendez vous de
14 heures à 18 heures et les infos sont
à retrouver bien sûr un sur le site
internet de la ville de trappes et les
jeunes qui étaient les invités de parly
2 le centre commercial situé au chesnay
a reçu des élèves de trois lycées
yvelinois ils ont pu découvrir les
coulisses du lieu qui reçoit plus de 12
millions de visiteurs par an une visite
organisée dans le cadre de la journée
nationale des jeunes à laquelle michael
et demi d'euros à assister c'était une
grande première le centre commercial
parly ii a ouvert ses portes à trois
lycées blinois ce jeudi 29 mars
après une introduction théorique d'une
heure les 60 étudiants ont pu découvrir
les espaces du site avec comme guide le
directeur du centre
le nôtre et il a depuis 1969 les
boucheries nivernaise pareil
sachez que les boucheries nivernaise
fournissant viande le palais de l'elysée
quand même voilà donc on a les traits
très belles maisons une opportunité pour
les étudiants de première et de seconde
destinée à une voie professionnelle dans
le commerce
j'ai trouvé cette journée très
enrichissante très bien et puis j'ai pu
découvrir différentes choses à prendre
le monde du travail
connaître plus le sens commercial
impressionné par la pertinence des
questions sur le nombre des visiteurs
les loyers l'activité les travaux le
fonctionnement du centre de sécurité
vigipirate jeunes s'ouvrent ou très
intéressés très avertis sur le suggérer
la visite a également permis de
présenter les différents secteurs et
métiers du centre qui compte 2200
emplois objectif susciter des vocations
je pense qu'à cet âge là on est en
recherche un petit peu sur des problèmes
en une intuition sur certains secteurs
d'activités vous mettiez qui pourrait
plaire là l'avantagé cette démarche
courante ont dû vraiment du concret
alors le marketing à paris deux c'est de
l'affichage urbain de la presse de la
radio avoir un message différent de
celui de la concurrence donc c'est ça
aurait choses plus concrètes et je pense
que ça peut un petit peu il est un jeune
dans son questionnement il son choix de
carrière
après une première édition réussie le
centre commercial devrait renouveler
l'expérience l'année prochaine avec
d'autres lycées du secteur
on referme ce journal sur cette grande
fête de l'athlétisme ce week-end à
guyancourt la 24e édition de l'avion
course se tenait ce dimanche départs et
arrêts est arrivé au gymnase et des
droits de l'homme est la compétition
était organisée par le club de l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
quatre courses au programme 3 pour les
enfants et le tracé phare de 10 km
autour des étangs de la minière
plus de 300 personnes ont pris part à ce
10 km elle les objectifs de la guillon
course expliqué au micro de nicolas
landry
c'est une fête qui portait aussi par des
parrains club d'athlétisme des gens qui
aiment tous la course à pied et donc qui
font des courses à pied et en quelque
part quand on fait de la course à pied
on a aussi envie de rendre et de
proposer des courses auto autres
personnes pour faire aimer ce sport où
j'en ai encore plus d'efforts à suivre
ce soir dans le 7-8 sport une mission
présentée par michael et demi d'euros et
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
reportages et replay à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]